now in today's legal minute we are
learning why you should hire an attorney
if you're accused of a DUI Eric Palacios
from Eric Palacios and Associates the
sponsors of this segment is here to tell
us more
hi I'm Eric Palacios welcome to the
legal minute this week's question is why
hire an attorney if you are accused of a
DUI there's three main reasons number
one to obtain better results an attorney
has a thorough understanding of DUI laws
and procedures and can provide you with
the best possible defense against these
charges number two protect your rights a
DUI attorney will ensure that your
constitutional rights are protected
throughout the legal process and will
fight to keep you out of jail and
protect your driving privileges and
number three minimizing the penalties a
DUI conviction can carry severe
penalties including jail time fines
license suspension and a permanent
criminal record an attorney can work to
negotiate a plea deal or litigate your
case in court to minimize these
penalties if you've been charged with a
DUI call an attorney right away
give Eric Palacios and Associates a call
or visit their website at Eric
palacioslaw.com